pour les carrières à longues on a vu à
l'assemblée qui a eu beaucoup de débats
et très peu de clarification vous pensez
pourquoi sur les 20-21 les 17 ans aussi
qu'est-ce qui a été décidé en commission
ah bah écoutez la Commission a adopter
le dispositif carrière longue proposé
sur le texte du Gouvernement qui dit je
le rappelle pour ces carrières longues
Trois Bornes une borne à 16 ans à 18 ans
et à 20 ans les deux premières porns
vous avez une durée de cotisation plus
un an la deuxième board 18 ans une durée
de cotisation plus un an et une durée de
cotisation pour la borne de 20 ans qui
est la durée de cotisation des 43 ans
d'agenca voilà donc on est arrivé sur ce
texte là à l'Assemblée nationale il y a
eu des avancées de fait qui n'ont pas
été votées puisqu'ils sont pas arrivés
jusque cet article 8 et qui font que la
première ministre a accepté n'a pas
accepté à proposer à proposer certes une
demande de certains mais à proposer de
mettre une quatrième borne voilà donc on
attend l'amendement éventuellement du
gouvernement dans ce dispositif
là pour mettre la quatrième board à 21
ans et puis également il y a eu la
première ministre a pris des engagements
concernant les durées nécessaires pour
ces bornes là et c'est si j'ai bien
compris elle a proposé que ce soit 43
ans pour tout le monde quel que soit les
bornes d'âge
à ce moment là il y a plus de carrière
longue si c'est 43 ans il y a des
carrières précoces mais il y a plus de
carrière là bon contact et ce sont des
dispositifs de plus en plus on vous
propose des agents anticipés de départ
bon c'est une réforme qui doit faire
travailler plus longtemps les gens et
dans ses dispositifs on vous propose de
pas les faire travailler plus longtemps
et même de façon anticiper donc acte
c'est de la responsabilité de la
première ministre on va voir ce qu'elle
nous présente nous nous sommes ouverts
aux discussions pour faire en sorte que
l'on trouve le plus de justice possible
et ce qui est important dans ce
dispositif c'est que soit pris en compte
ceux qui travaillent de bonheur ce
notamment qui sont par la filière
apprentissage parce que ces gens-là ils
ont commencé ils ont des métiers qui
sont sûrement plus difficiles que celui
qui a fait des études j'en fais partie
je peux en parler et qui commence un peu
plus longtemps mais qui ont peut-être
une pénibilité un peu différente par
rapport à ceux qui ont les notamment des
carrières plus manuelles et voilà donc
il faut pas perdre d'objectif cela parce
que si on est là je dis les bords on
perd un peu les objectifs de départ et
on arrive de toute façon dans les
dispositifs proposés mais qui sont après
par voie réglementaire à ne pas
satisfaire tout le monde parce que même
si on dit que la durée d'âge assurance
requise sera de 43 ans pour tout le
monde même les bornes quand vous
regardez les dispositifs de bornes vous
avez des gens qui auront 40 ans voilà
donc ça ne répond pas à toutes les
préoccupations on emprunte on verra
maintenant ce que nous propose le
gouvernement par rapport à ces carrières
longues nous la Commission on a
travaillé sur le texte une iso proposé
donc trois bornes et des durées telles
que je vous les ai précisés
pardonnez-moi de la complexité mais ces
dispositifs sont tels que il est bien
difficile de les faire bien sûr
comprendre par nos concitoyens parce que
parfois ils sont même incompréhensibles
pour nous
quand on rentre dans le texte
au cours des discussions
[Musique]
et est-ce qu'il a évoqué à nouveau parce
que à l'Assemblée les débats a été
vraiment pas très clair les propositions
de bornes ou des propositions du
ministre du socle on a rien compris ou
pas compris grand chose dans tous les
cas pas lever les doutes est-ce que le
gouvernement était plus clair avec vous
sur cet aspect là alors pour l'instant
nous les avons dit que nous étions
sensibles à ce dispositif qu'il fallait
semble-t-il l'éclaircir par rapport à ce
qu'il y avait été annoncé donc nous
attendons maintenant les propositions
qui vont être faites et voir surtout
s'il dépose des amendements similaires à
ceux qu'ils avaient déposé à l'Assemblée
nationale et qui n'ont pas été examinés
puisqu'ils sont arrêtés avant donc
aujourd'hui on n'a pas l'incertitude de
l'action que fera le gouvernement faut
lui poser la question au gouvernement
c'est pas nous qu'il faut la poser on va
voir la façon dont il souhaite modifier
ses textes
Article 8 article 8 nos négociations à
ce jour ne sont qu'avec les conseillers
de Matignon et de des messages de
travail on aura
on aura des négociations sans doute
demain avec le ministre puisque nous
devons le rencontrer en fin d'après-midi
mais ces histoires de retraite anticipée
pour carrière longue sont extrêmement
techniques et difficiles à comprendre
parce que il y a la borne d'âge mais il
y a aussi le nombre d'annuités et puis
il y a effectivement l'idée que quand on
parle de carrière longue il faut
effectivement qu'elle soit longue or
aller jusqu'à 21 ans c'est quand même
déjà coûteux et je me demande si on
parle vraiment de carrière longue parce
que avant 20 ans oui c'est des carrières
longues mais après 20 ans là on peut
déjà se poser la question parce que
finalement avec 43 annuités comme c'est
peut-être proposé par le gouvernement là
ça fait pas des carrière longue en fait
c'est des carrières je dirais normal
[Musique]
c'est pareil vous avez bien compris le
dispositif de 4 à 5 trimestres avant
l'année la fin de l'année avec je
rappelle
à la fois par rapport au coût important
que cela générer et comme l'a dit René
Paul Savary par rapport aussi au
caractère un peu inégalitaire de ces
mesures après après c'est la
responsabilité du gouvernement le
confirmer donne confirmer on verra le
texte qui nous vient
du gouvernement est-ce que propose en
effet le Gouvernement sur ce dispositif
carrière longue nous on a fait part de
nos remarques de nos interrogations
après en fonction de ce qui arrivera on
verra ce que l'on fait
[Musique]